[Music]
hello we're going talk about three very
important things as signified by this
very important looking slide we're going
talk about the 1990s we're going to talk
about JavaScript we talked about style
sheets that wasn't totally clear my name
is Steve guinea uh I have a very unique
Twitter handle Steve Kinning where you
can hear me complain about the current
members of blink-182 as well as retweet
many of the tweets from an account for a
JavaScript family of conference this
conference in Denver Colorado's if you
want to come visit Colorado this summer
and see Tom and see Monica and a bunch
of you saw this weekend you want to see
them again I will have the the encore
presentation in Denver on June 15th and
16th the director emeritus of the Turing
school of software and designs is going
to talk about teaching or learning or
any that kind of stuff come find me
afterwards but right now I am a senior
front-end engineer at SendGrid it's in
great if you've ever gotten a receipt
from uber or Spotify or sing along those
lines handle that with an API so that
nobody else has to deal with SMTP I work
on the marketing emails client which
means I take arbitrary user markup and
CSS and then try to create a
drag-and-drop editor and then try to
make something that works in Outlook
2007 Outlook 2007 is a wonderful
platform if you ever thought like ie6
was rough outlooks basically said to ie6
hold my dear and it uses words rendering
engine so you want to talk about
conditional Outlook tags and table based
layouts also come talk to me after this
and I work at a book called electron in
action our story begins today in the
year 1996 the best part about doing a
slide deck on the 90s is that all like
taste goes out the window and you can
use all of those animations and
transitions you never thought possible
so let's just like get our head space
for 1996 let's remember what it was like
for those of us that were around the
popular cell phone at the time did not
have a headphone jack we walked around
catching digital pets we neglected that
digital pets we cloned a sheep
we also cloned the Beatles and this
happened Rachel gave us a little bit of
a taste yesterday of some of the the
wonderment that was the web in the 90s
of a very cultural standpoint I myself
was a web developer at age 12 I had made
a website of MORTAL KOMBAT cheat codes
yeah
it was really great I had a bunch of
animated gifts for no good reason there
was little to no concern for
accessibility it took about three
minutes to download all the assets and
an autoplay obnoxious media files
without the users consent so it was like
a basic of website in 2017 I don't have
any screenshots of that web pages on
Geocities and has been lost the time but
I did find this doom website which is
pretty much my aesthetic at the time
same kind of like just imagine
everything doom like instead being
Mortal Kombat but same like background
same like divider bar everything along
those lines some other just some other
websites of the time on geo cities that
you could find yes yes Bobby you do you
can see I also has a MIDI file which is
great and I don't know what the serpent
says divinity means and the way that you
made websites at the time was you
basically took all your basic styles and
you inline them in style tags and you
could carry would keep this going as you
went every like subsequent tag if the
background color needed to change so if
we wanted to have a a marquee with a
different background color we could do
that you laugh at the marquee tag
but this is what I write in my
day-to-day job right now which is table
based layouts so I still live in this
world and I know it very well and I like
this is this is not a retrospective for
me this is my day-to-day but yeah you
laugh at the Marquee tag I will let you
know that it still works in chrome today
it can be used if that is that is the
design aesthetic that you are going for
so the page got on a web ring and that
was great I think I got listed on a
sub-directory on Yahoo and you might say
a web ring who needs more than one
Mortal Kombat g-code web site all three
things I was 12 give me a break
that's off-topic try to try to stay on
topic try to focus and just keep that in
mind next to me why I want to write a
medium thing piece about JavaScript
fatigue school so the hit counter hit a
hundred which is very impressive
considering that I was paying by minute
so to visit my web page that many times
so it was time for a redesign and going
through and updating all those tags can
best be described in this stock
photograph to give you a sense for those
who did not have to update the page in
90s it was like migrating from one
version angular to the next whoo let's
we were framed so you had isolated
components that could capture their own
style again you laugh still supported in
Chrome cool so the things that were
coming you know the discussion of the
time with stylesheet' right and some of
those things that we talked about say
existed at the time but I was unaware of
them the in fact the first web browser
the one developed at CERN by Sir Tim
berners-lee you might know him as a web
developer actually had support for this
thing called stylesheets right there
wasn't a formal shared syntax but the
browser itself supported this idea that
you could define what all the style
should look like and in fact the voila
browser was one of the first browsers to
kind of implement this and ship it it is
very hard to find screenshots from the
early 90s any bigger than this by the
way so luckily these screens are very
large mosaic browser actually took a
step back and didn't allow users to
define style sheets a lot of the reason
a lot of the research for this talk I
had to look up you know go through like
mailing list and somebody said hey I
noticed that mosaic renders something
different than links and I was wondering
if as a user I could have any control
over that to wick to which the response
to Marc Andreessen was in fact it has
been a constant source of delight for me
over the past year to get to continually
tell hordes literally of people who want
to strap yourselves in here comes
control what their documents look like
in ways that would not be trivial or the
way that would be trivial in text makers
have word every other common text
processing environment sorry you're
screwed and the idea of style sheets was
that the browser could have some say and
what an h1 should look like our
paragraph and then ideally the user
could also do that until somebody threw
a reset CSS in there and just blew it
all away netscape supported this it's
still present in modern browsers like
firefox safari will actually let you
like upload a stylesheet but there was a
third group of people who wanted to also
have some say over the style of their
web page all the time authors like
yourself and myself with their very
important MORTAL KOMBAT web pages
now we want to like doctor say these
people could be trusted
this is literally a website that I
designed in 2004 so there's no
accounting for taste when people got
access to these style sheets but there
we go there were a few solutions this
problem there was about as many as 10
different implementations of style
sheets at the time we're only going to
talk about two of them CSS and
JavaScript style sheets
there was no logo for JavaScript style
sheet so I took the worst JavaScript
logo I could find and put some Comic
Sans underneath it it felt only fair to
also grab a non-official worst-possible
logo for CSS JavaScript style sheets
came about in netscape 4.0 and that was
the the only time they were seen in the
wild so let's take a look at what some
of these style sheets look like let's
leave and here we go we have a modern
web browser and some markup so there's
some tasting notes here you'll notice
that we have a link a stylesheet link
but it goes to this jas instead of a CSS
right that is the first clue you might
be using javascript style sheets after
that we have some very non non exciting
markup careful readers will notice the
Sagan if some on there we've got a
little bit of form and stuff along those
lines one thing that I learned along the
way is that there was no document dot
get element by ID yet so adding a lot of
different interactivity was very
difficult at the time in fact Netscape
threw away the Dom after it rendered it
and just to show the original version
there so it limited a lot of what you
could do at the time but let's let's
play around with it for a second so we
go into style dot J s we can see that
there's nothing right now
but we could theoretically right o
document let's see document tags h1 had
to be capitalized color is red cool and
let's go ahead and refresh that and you
see that our lovely h1 turns turns red
oh there's some other things that we
might want to do for instance in the
notes they said make sure that your
fonts are 24 pixels so everyone can see
them
so let's put that in as well and you can
see we can style individual tags so then
well I know CSS right I don't use dots
for classes how do we do that well we
had a slightly different way of doing
that we could say document and the
document was actually arbitrary like it
was like window it was a global all the
time we could say classes and we could
say I believe that it was called first
right as our first paragraph
you do have to say like what kind of tag
that would be so you could say a P and
then you could say background color we
equals green I don't know why not we've
seen my taste already can't hear it
save that this editor is textmate is not
part of the 90s joke is from the 2000
and it's not funny
um and so now we have the background
color green
you could also say if you want to get
everything with a class of first which
is this is the only one you could say
all right now would be all tags in this
situation cool but JavaScript fellows
has some other like really interesting
things they had variables right so I
could say var color is equal to green
and I could use that as well
all right cool and you see that works as
well so we had we have variables we
actually had all of the JavaScript
programming language available to us
that means we had functions it means
that we had conditional statements as
well we could use any of those you could
even if you really wanted to add a
little bit of uncertainty to your
webpage right and you could say hey give
me a random number and rounded either
zero one and use that as the background
color of the page save that and flip
over and sometimes will be black and
sometimes it would be white yet most of
the JavaScript programming language
available to you so you could set the
variables and use it all together so you
could say something like if you wanted
to implement a dark mode which is very
popular in like 2010 go ahead and do
that as well and now if it was in dark
mode you got these you got these
different colors versus if that was not
such a true in fact you could do some
interesting things because you had stuff
like confirm so you could ask the user
did they want to go back to the dark
mode and they could say true or false
and good style it based on user input
right if if writing document and tags
every time was to verb
we could go ahead and use everyone's
friend the with keyword in JavaScript
and get the same basic effect as well it
works on some kind of interesting things
you could do as well where the page was
evaluated pretty whenever it's hard to
tell because I don't have any developer
tools and there's no events or anything
like that but here we'll say hey when
the stylesheet loads let's measure the
inner width and if it's less than 600
let's make the background color red
otherwise we'll make it blue right like
a very early days media queries so here
we go and if I grab the edge of this can
he grab the edge let's grab this corner
down here you can see that we have like
the very beginnings of responsive design
in 1995 when you would have been looking
at your Motorola StarTAC cool and
there's all sorts of like fun things
that we could have done in this land
some of them like the web itself wasn't
wasn't ready for the sheer awesomeness
the JavaScript scousers would behold
like stuff like the ability to have
vendor prefixes there were no vendor
prefixes yet but like--imagine or
something like view with and kind of
like great creating our own extra units
we had the full power of a programming
language to figure out how we style
things cool so that concludes our live
coding portion of the show there were
still things like specificity right so
you weren't getting away from that one
and it followed the same rules that it
did back is the same rules that it
follows now we'll talk about why that
was in a second there were a bunch of
things there was a submission to the w3c
to make it part of a spec and none of
that it never became to be so there were
some things that were in the Specht it
didn't actually work in that scape as
far as I can tell one interesting one
was evaluate style and you could be like
where's the function keyword I literally
don't know I tried it with him without
this is what it's just shown literally
in the spec and you could use functions
to evaluate based on other parts of the
of the style sheets
what another style should be why you
would use in this case
I don't know but there it is and then
you use it you're going to apply it to
all sorts of different things and people
were very excited about this right the
big thing about JSF s is because the
extension of JavaScript you could change
the color of font size you know based on
user interaction right and like spoiler
I think this is something we're still
chasing now so the we all know how this
story ends
CSS was adopted by Internet Explorer 3
and really for realsies and for and
except as a standard to the w3c so your
options were you could in Netscape write
CSS or JavaScript style sheets new logo
or for in explore you can only write CSS
so most developers made the obvious
choice and just wrote CSS it turns out
Netscape really thought JavaScript style
sheets were going to be the be-all and
end-all and the CSS support in Netscape
actually just shelled out to JavaScript
style sheets and that's kind of why I
was a little flaky and so in 1997 like
The Fresh Prince of bel-air JavaScript
style sheets ultimately came to a close
they were removed in Netscape Navigator
sticks with the new gecko rendering
engine and it's kind of sad because I
think there's a lot of missed
opportunities here like what if you know
throughout the kind of 2000s even today
we could have used moderniser
to do feature detection and then have a
alternative style sheet on the fly and I
have some logic in there to figure out
how to fall back to other like more
supported properties you can imagine
this is fictitious code you can imagine
a world where we could have
asynchronously had code split CSS files
or JavaScript stylesheet files and
loaded them in on the fly based on the
user navigating to a certain part of the
application or taking a given action you
could theoretically even do this based
on user action right if you had this
interrupt right in my experimentation if
you put a variable on the window object
you could actually access it in your
JavaScript later on you didn't work the
other way again I don't fully know why
but you did have like in this fictitious
perfect world we can see a world where
we could like all of a sudden have
interaction between JavaScript and our
Styles so like I said javascript
associates didn't make it but like a
bunch of ideas really like have kept
cropping up over and over and over again
for last 20 years sass and less gave us
functions and variables and conditionals
right and like these were like a big you
know like a really powerful way in the
way we style things today
jQuery even took this idea of finding by
a selector and be able to manipulate the
way something looked to a to another
level as well and CSS for brought us
variables and even some functions like
calc right so these are ideas that we
really didn't survive in the first
iteration there are ones that we have
like looked at over and over again have
like crept up but all of these CSS for
aside have some limitations a very
handsome man one Judy line between
static analysis and dynamic analysis we
couldn't have something like a random
stylesheet with sass or even running
something through post CSS because we we
come up with at random number at runtime
right all right but build time we can't
we don't have any of that introspection
that we had potentially with the real
JavaScript saw states or my completely
fictitious examples earlier we do have a
little bit of access with the sinkhole
the CSS object model which you may or
may not have ever heard of it is very
cool but kind of incomplete basically
you open up your chrome developer tools
in Firefox developer tools and you go to
document down style sheets you can
actually access all the style sheets
that have been loaded by the browser and
kind of like look at all their rules
actually insert rules and delete rules
kind of on the fly it's really cool but
it has some limitations one cross-origin
sheets no working two is that there's no
real way to traverse it so this is an
example where you can like navigate
through but like you need to know kind
of the order you could iterate it as an
array like object so you could loop over
it and that will get you this amazing
effect as we change the background color
of the body on a set interval
right and we could be ready to implement
some of those fake ideas from JavaScript
shots to swivel again the it's under
SPECT
so it's not clear how it works all times
on every browser and generally speaking
not our best option and we also don't
really have the tools to work with it
most browsers come with all browsers
come with a Dom parser that let us
actually like manipulate write we could
use something like post CSS read the
style tag and try to do all the stuff at
runtime but it doesn't really work out
so great as our craft is kind of
developed we've taken this giant
document viewer and tried to build into
a world's most distributed application
platform and our craft has definitely
evolved and over the time we've like as
JavaScript developers like taken on
these very different like techniques
let's like not pull the goal name scape
and keep everything in there fees
turns out object that has on property
just not working in sp8 navigator 4 and
we've kind of like first I think by
walking this like kind of like code of
honor to implement stuff we've been able
to kind of move the web forward but
eventually we just made our tools better
right and then eventually made the
platform better I think really strongly
that like a way that we've made jobs we
have such an amazing application
platform it's kind of like following
pattern doing things we were not
supposed to do working around the hard
parts automating Network and eventually
fixing the platform itself and as we've
come to this component based approach to
building user interfaces where
everything is isolated and encapsulated
we've decided that it's CSS that's
limiting us at this point and there are
some really good points to this right
also are in the global scope it's tricky
to figure out dependencies dead code
elimination is hard
sharing constant unless you're like me
and Ruby on Rails in 2010 er being
things into my templates don't do that
like all these these are very these are
big problems like writing over another
style this you know it's very very
mutable whatever came last wins in a lot
of cases but I noticed that people who
knew CSS really well didn't we're
arguing that the same wasn't like we
didn't like didn't see the same thing
and I'd always take pause when when we
find ourselves and somebody who knows
something more than I do doesn't see
this is the problem in the same way and
I thought a lot about this I came from
Ruby originally
and you know a few years ago you it was
not not too uncommon to see things like
this and you had to ask yourself a
question are we falling into the same
trap right we said javascript couldn't
be used to build robust web applications
right and so as we find ourselves saying
that CSS was broken I think that that is
a trap of the way we think about these
things
javascript obviously can be used to
build applications it has been used even
some of those posts have recanted since
then and I wonder if we need to think
about that in terms of our relationship
with CSS because CSS does it you know it
does have its rough edges but who
amongst us is not and there's some
really powerful things that CSS does
right
this is CSS Zen garden in the same
markup with different style sheets can
be used to really transform applications
in amazing ways and this is an argument
made in as a response to the previous
quote saying that like hey maybe we
don't want a couple the way our
applications look right yes we could
pass everything into every component but
what happens when it comes time for to
change the font across the entire page
because marketing right and this is one
point of the end why throw the baby out
with the bathwater there are some parts
of CSS that are troublesome for the way
we build UIs but there's also some
really interesting and great parts I
like right now we can't inline our Seles
with SendGrid because we have a
marionette and backbone app along with a
react app along with a wordpress site
like we can't like move to an entirely
new approach in one application through
their style to develop by the same team
right so I think a lot about this graph
right I think we solved some of it with
build tools all right we have style lint
in post CSS we've got CSS modules that
allow us to build up a style sheet based
on like imports across our different
files we can even make sure that one
style isn't stepping over another one
with immutable CSS as far as like the
encapsulation right we have standards
that we're working towards to solve
these problems that don't throw out CSS
in the process right and I think a
little bit other static and dynamic
analysis that we talked about yesterday
with something that I would like to see
improved in the platform is improved
cycle time better insight Nexus at run
time right and when I was kind of like
one of things mean the most to me in
terms of like developing this platform
is this thing called the extensible web
manifesto which some people in the room
have signed it's this idea that we you
know kind of expose low-level api's
allow people to build ideas and like you
know give greater insight and access
into the platform itself right and be
able to make it possible to polyfill
more features that we want to see and
you know look at those kind of paths and
see what we advance the platform into
being right you saw tc39 up here earlier
kind of making that point of you saw
some of the process and some of the you
know be kind of like ways to get
involved as a developer and there's a
there's some test of the test code right
now as w3c called Houdini to expose the
same low-level API so he looks like a
vampire there expose those same
low-level API as to us right right now
we have access to the Dom so all of our
solutions involved let's just modify the
DOM and stuff along those lines we have
this partial access to the CSS object
model but there's a lot we don't have
access to quote Marc Andreessen and the
idea of looting is to give us access to
a lot of these parts of the entire
process that we didn't have access to
previous previously javascript style
sheets were short-lived but there are
some ideas that obviously carried around
over the last 20 years
right now we're solving problems with
the best tools that we have but I think
it's exciting to look at what tools we
could have right thinking about what we
would like to like what what are we
doing now that we would love the browser
to be able to do for us and figuring out
like what we want the web platform to be
about an hour ago Jen said this quote
which I absolutely loved the nice thing
about being the like one of the last
talks is you can like steal everyone
else's idea is that standards without
community involvement are not standards
period so I leave you with this moral of
the story rather than work around the
limitations let's push to create the web
platform we want even that means we're
looking into the past well let's
actually figure out what we want the
browser to do for us and how we want to
interact with the web
and let's start making that happen thank
you
[Applause]